it's been a struggle to watch it back
because I saw I was really working
through some things that I needed to
deal with and so you know as hard as it
was though it's it is kind of
therapeutic on the other side to know
that I was able to work through some of
those things again that wasn't the
initial objective of coming on to the
show but you know I think I'm better for
it there was one experience of kind of
living it and then there's the secondary
experience of watching it back right
after the show wrapped I had a really
tough time I had you know kind of take
some time for myself and get through
therapy and stuff like that went home
moved back to Chicago just to be close
for family and now I'm out in LA and I
feel like I'm having a fresh start and I
feel really good about where I'm at and
you know finally starting to open myself
up again but wouldn't be able to do that
without the lessons that I learned here
and you know from mark have you been in
touch I think both of us needed our own
kind of time to like figure things out
like she said I'm kind of a lude to it
like she needed her time and like I
needed my time and like we both kind of
what both the type of people they need
to figure it out our own way and so I
you know I've never been mad like we
both didn't haven't really reached out
but it like I knew like eventually we'll
see each other again it would be fine
like it's not like like I know that this
whole journey was a lot and so like it's
one thing to be there for each other
it's another thing I'm like okay we need
our own separate space to go and be our
own people and like figure this out on
our own and then like now at the Reunion
kind of coming together and like being
able to communicate those feelings
because I don't think we would have been
able to communicate that had we talked
like maybe a week later or a month later
or even like you know a year later so
it's been a year and some change though
we went through something together and
you know whatever I I want her to be
nothing but the most successful person
out there for her in her life and
whatever she goes through and like if
she ever didn't need me like reach out
to me and like just wanted to talk I'd
be there I'm not you know what whatever
happened today like was real and I
really do appreciate the whole journey
and like what we went through and so
like that's why I can thank you for
everything that like Who I am today is
because of like what we do and whatever
you if you ever need something like
don't hesitate to call and that's why I
like I hope that like people like stop
giving so much flag because like we were
both just two people trying to figure
and now we're here were two better
people for it and like she said I I
think we both needed to be ready at that
point and now I feel like we can give
that to someone else and just at the end
of the day to support each other we're
connected for life so no one is ever
gonna understand how crazy this was this
is Season one it's not like Oh bachelor
that's been running for 17 seasons it's
really we got to put ourselves out there
and to sign up for this you know we were
in it together I mean we're always
you're always gonna have a friend I was
coming down off a bomb there were 48
hours in the day I thought about you for
like 46 of those hours it's like it was
insane to see her throwing herself at
him in Mexico [ __ ] you're sheisty
you're so fake coming to my face like we
were cool you were so fake I think you
were a very distant genuine person and
you know what I hope seeing this you do
grow from it because that is not what
the world needs is women that go behind
people's backs like that you were
engaged to another man that you were
leading on I totally understood where
she was coming from because watching it
back it really looks like you know I was
going after her guy and I wanted to just
let her know that's you know not
necessarily exactly what was going on I
was working through some things and that
type of persona was somebody I would
normally go for you know when I have
like the perfect thing right there so I
totally understood and I came in today
like definitely knowing that I owed them
both an apology
I think Barnett has gotten a lot of heat
about being this player but you can't
expect someone to go into this
experience and not open themselves up
and really get there with as many people
as possible to vet it out for themselves
when you're literally you have literally
11 days so you know I don't think he
really deserves accolade Flair they had
their journey we had our journey and
like now it's like shared the emotions
you just see it live right there like
right on TV but now it's like okay I'm
just like calm down like these motions
were high like we're okay like and now I
think we can kind of understand and look
back at it after we've all communicated
and kind of expressed how we felt
like guys it was just a really
heightened experience so we just all
came out on the other end learning way
more would you do it again I would I
would do it differently I wish I was
more ready and I wish I had kind of
dealt with some of the challenges that I
was experiencing
[Music]